Hello, I'm Sean Hayes. I'm an actor. Special skills include being able to bounce a tennis ball on a racket 153 consecutive times. Another special skill is picking my nose without people watching or people knowing. Shit. Welcome to SmartLess. Sean, I don't think I've ever seen you grumpy, ever. Oh, yeah. Well, I'll live with me for a couple of days. Oh, challenge much. But what gets you grumpy? I mean, I guess only, I guess Scotty would be the answer to that. That's what gets you grumpy. That's why I haven't seen it, huh?
Sometimes Scotty makes you grumpy. Well, look, when you live with somebody, right, doesn't Amanda make you grumpy? Everybody, every spouse makes him grumpy. Yeah. Why would you ask that question? And you make her grumpy and we all make each other grumpy. It is, you know, actually Amanda and I had a nice talk about that. Oh, recently? Yeah. Basically like, well, this is, it's a choice.
It's a real choice. Like, it's pretty easy to stay grumpy, make your partner grumpy and just live in grumpiness. It's, it's, it's, it's life-lifting. Yeah. Yeah. But, uh, it's such a small. Well, I always say you have to fall in respect with somebody, not in love with them, because if you don't have respect, you don't have love. Yeah, you can say that.
Have you ever thought about making it on t-shirts or something? Like. Or even a bumper sticker. Yeah, you got everything like a center, like up in New York. No, you know what? You know what? You know our friend Josh Shotland said to me the other day, Willie, um, he passed on a, a sage saying, um, you'll never treat anyone better than you treat yourself. Oh, there you go.
So, you know. Well, here's what, here's something Scottie and I argued about yesterday. We, he was talking about having a meeting with this person for a potential gig, because he's a composer. He writes music. And so I was like, I jumped all over him about, this is what you got to do. You got to talk to him like this. You got to bring it. And when you bring your stuff, make sure you show him this music that you did. And then this music, but it's got to be in this order because it grows. See from this, from the ballot to the more complicated. I'm already mad at you.
He looks at me like he's going to fucking kill me. Right. Like, Hey, Hollywood, how about I just take a nice meeting? Just, I've been doing well just by myself. And I was like, okay. And so, uh, and I go, I'm just, I'm just here to help. And he goes, see a loser. Is that what she said to her kicked him in the ass. And then he got. But I say, but I say, I said, I'm only trying to help you. And he was, I know that. But sometimes you don't hear your, the way you hear yourself.
So Sean, that's a great point. I think that for me, one of the things that I noticed that has taken me a long time is tone. And sometimes people misinterpret my tone. And I get very, uh, uh, I get very sort of fired up about stuff or whatever. And they, this is everybody. This is sort of friends, kids, um, partners, whatever. But I live for when you get fired up. I love that. And I just, but I actually don't mean it. And I think that what happens is people misinterpret it anyway. I tend to, I tend to get, uh, uh, uh, insincerely passionate about things too. Um, uh, but
also my, that heavy brow of mine at 53, uh, we've talked about this. I, I look, I look pretty, pretty pissed off just when listening. Um, your brow is now where your eyes are. Yeah. My bad mood is just gravity. That's all that is. Don't worry. Um, gang, um, I got, um, uh, I got, um, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, I got a real peach for us today. Today's guest, this fella is smart and handsome. He's famous, but private. An academic but disarming. He's got a degree from Yale, his own show, couple kids, 19 Emmys.
What? Yeah. He's worked in over 40 countries. He's written three books, all of them best sellers, and He's just launched a podcast because we need more. We needed more and that's why we got into it. Yeah. We're gonna have, we're gonna have to ask him what Stimuliti's addicted to to get all this done
and why he's agreed to do our show. I'm a big, big long time fan and super excited to welcome Anderson Cooper. Oh my! Come on in Anderson. Mr. Anderson Cooper. Yeah. How's it going? Wait, 19 Emmys. 19 Emmys. You know they're news Emmys though
so it's not real. Sure. Still gold. Hey, nobody cares. There's not a ceremony. There's no one watching it. Yes, there is. Yes, there is.
I remember visiting you in your office. Yeah, Sean, I think you're the only, in this trio, the only one person I've actually met. But I'm, I'm, I'm intimidated. I'm a huge admirer of everybody here. So I love your podcasts. I've listened. I'm the least successful Cooper ever on your podcast,
by the way. Where do we book TB? Hey, what, what? I just, your level of accomplishments are just, they're pretty stunning. And I'm just going to go start right on question 11. By the way, am I the only one without a hat? Yeah.
Yeah. We told you to get a hat. Will we have access to one or? You had time to get one when I asked you to. I mean, I got this. That'll work. Okay, that's good. Listener, he's just put on a war correspondent helmet.
This is the first person who's been embedded with SmartLess. I want, I'm going to get to that. But I want- Listen, did you just play golf? I mean, is this- Wait, no, I don't. I don't play golf. I don't play golf.
Do you want to see my shorts? You were on like a, last I heard, you were on a like a every day for the last 101 days or something. Yeah. I'm trying to catch up a little bit. Willie's going to jump into the hole with me on Tuesday. I beg your pardon.
I'm back. Yeah, I'm back Tuesday. No, I'm back Saturday. Is there a better way to say that? I know. There's a much better way. So long. Wait, wait, wait, wait.
No, here comes my question. What about, all these accomplishments- We're so excited. This is an easy but tough question. What's left? What do you want to do, Anderson? Tell me what the goal is. You just jumped to the end?
I know, to be honest with you. I'm working on, at the end of the interview, I'm working on an ice show. Do you have ice? You're going to go ice skating? No, it's going to be like, it's like Anderson on ice kind of thing. Kind of a review of my life, but on ice.
Okay. Shaking, not stirring. It's the same costume designer as Shrek on ice. Yeah. You're just going to use all those same costumes. Some plays my mom and my dad. It's a great answer. My dad brother.
You know, it's going to be really good. Listen, I have some experience. I have a lot of experience with ice productions. So, you know, just let me know. I played a figure skater. No, but Willie knows his way around an ice rink, you know? He's got a real power dumper on him and he can get after it.
What's a power dumper? Power dumper's what skaters get. It's a pro dumper. Oh, you mean like a big butt? Pro dumper. It's a pro dumper. Yeah, it's a shelf. It's called a pro dumper.
That's what hockey guys have. We had pro dumper. Like muscle ass, like a big muscle ass. Bro, thank you, Sean, for putting into terms like an understand. Yeah, gay muscle ass. So, all right. So you're not going to give me an honest answer
because to do that would be... What was it? Well, you're too humble to give me a real answer about what's left, what is next? What would you... What is there left for you to do? I mean, you know, 360 is enough, but you're also on 60 minutes for God's sake.
Like you're at the pinnacle of any journalistic goal. I'm Leslie Stahl. I'm Anderson Cooper every Sunday. Like what else would you want? And you've written books. You know, my dad died at 50 and I always expected to die at 50. So I planned my whole life in an accelerated version
of I'm going to die at 50. So I need to get everything in by then. Can I be honest with you? None of us thought you were going to make it past 50. We all lost. So when I hit 51, I was like, what the fuck do I do now? I don't have a plan.
And so I have been asking myself that question for the last couple of years and I have kids now and that is the greatest thing I've ever done. And so that's a whole, that's my future. And I love, I like what I do. I mean, I love, you know, I love telling other people's stories.
So, I mean, I have no actual skills so there's nothing else I can do. Oh, please. You're brilliant, you're brilliant. You've got your degree in political science. You're actually succeeding in something you studied. Plus you had to spend one night a year on TV with Andy Cohen, which is a skill in and of itself.
I mean, what a handful that guy is. Jesus Christ. Hey, Will, do you know? I do know Andy. I do know Andy. Yeah, no, no, no, I've known Andy for a long time. I would like to know him. He and I were set up on a blind date like 25 years ago.
No way. Were you really? How'd that go? Oh, we never had it because he called, he was a producer at CBS News at the time on the morning show. And people were like, oh, you're gay and you're both in news, so you should meet.
And anyway, he called me up to set up the date and within 30 seconds I knew I was never going on a date with Andy Cohen because he violated like every one of my rules and the biggest one being, he mentioned my mom within the first 30 seconds and he now admits he just wanted to date the Vanderbilt boys. Sure, that was so gauche. Wait a second.
So for my sister, your mom's Glory of Vanderbilt. This is killing me. That is so unbranded for Andy. It's so amazing. How did he bring it up? Oh, he was just like your Glory of Vanderbilt's son. I mean, he's not subtle. Hey, did you guys ever make a pact that like
if he's single by a certain age and you're single by a certain age, sure, let's just get together and mine families? No, it's not possible. We're really close friends. I mean, I love him, but that would not work. I love it. By the way, Sean, you said that
and Andy is such a great guy. I love him. He's so profoundly funny to me. He makes me, he really cracks me up. Why don't you bring him on the show, aren't that? Well, just because I can't, I don't know. It's just a lot. But no, no, I'm kidding.
I love him. I am gonna have him on the show. But it's funny, Sean, you bring up the thing about, hey, we make a pact. You know what people say of that all the time? Like so-and-so, we made a pact that if we weren't married by, and I always call it like, that's just bullshit. That's like some weird bullshit old thing that people do.
Has anyone ever done that? No, nobody's ever done it. And they all talk about it in this way that's really stupid and nostalgic. Oh, thank you. And just full of BS. All right, we'll be right back. We take commercials, right?
We do commercials on this show. We don't, not anymore. I like the commercials you guys do. So was that some of that, that was some of that passion, often misinterpreted for hostility? Yeah, yeah, by the way, I don't really care about it. All right, somebody asked him a question. I gotta go to my question list.
Oh yeah, no, I wanna know. So when you go, when I walked into your office, I don't know, this is like three years ago. I flew to, I flew from LA to New York to CNN to do three commercials in one day and then flew home. And I stopped and I was like running on fumes. I ran into your office and I think I made a fool out of myself.
I was like, Anderson, what's going on? Got into any, you have any, I'm Emmys done in the back and she's got like 19 Emmys in the back. Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. And I made like joke, joke, joke. And then I left and you're probably like, How did you describe that encounter, Anderson,
to other people? It was like the greatest thing that had happened to me for like the month. That was the first time we met. Come on. And then I did a little interview with you for the doctor you were working on. Yeah, that's right.
Thank you for that. Anderson, tell me how journalism got started with you. Why did you get excited about it and at what age? I, you know, I watched a lot of news as a kid growing up. I was a total nerd and I was interested in how stories are told. My dad was a writer and my mom wrote. And so, yeah, we, we didn't-
Who's your mom? Nice, nice. Will's trying to date you. And I watched news like while eating dinner because, you know, it was better than actually talking to anybody. And so, but I never really thought I would do it. And I went to college and was,
I actually interned at the CIA and I decided not to do that. What? What? And I- He knew we were gonna ask about that. All the stuff I was interested in was going overseas and experiencing stuff. And so, yeah, I made a fake,
I had a friend make a fake press pass for me and I borrowed a camera and I started going to wars. No way. That's so crazy. Wow, really? No way. What was fascinating about, what was fascinating about that to you?
Like, I always find that fascinating, like just from a viewer is like, why do they have to stand in the war zone? Can't they just tell us about it from somewhere safe? Actually, no, I like, you do, I mean, there's nothing, nothing can compare to actually being in a place. But like, but also like when they're standing
in the middle of a hurricane, forget the war, but we're standing in the middle of a hurricane. You don't have to do that. Yeah, we can just see that it's bad outside. You know, it's funny, when news organizations, when a big news story breaks and you go and I've seen you at so many,
they've been hurricanes or big wars or whatever, you've done it all, we've all seen you, America, the world has seen you there. But it is funny when some big event happens, the race for news people to get on site is kind of like when someone famous dies and go to Wikipedia to see who writes it
on their page first. It's like this. Who's fastest to make it about them? Yeah. Well, no, not about them. I actually mean more like just to get there. Like I'm always surprised. It almost. On the scene.
Yeah, I can't believe it. Like, so that's my followup question is, what happens, Russia invades Ukraine, let's say, or something of that, how quickly does that decision get made? Like you're, I don't know, you're at the gym. You might not even be at work or you're with your family. And then all of a sudden you're,
is it 30 seconds and you're out the door? Basically, yeah. I mean, I have like a go bag and I keep my passport with me at all times. Like a bat signal, but it's the Cooper signal. What's in the go bag? Yeah, what is it? How many pairs of underwear?
Like two. Underwear is not important. Hey, there he is. Not fair. Hey, man. I'm taking, bro. Come on. So it's just, it's just two pair.
God. It's just two pair? Yeah. I mean, these, but. Do you really have something, like, are you prepared to go in with it? There's like, there's a pair, I'll tell you, there's like a pair of boots,
steel-toed boots. Sure. There's, you know, like, it's mostly like food supplies, some like technical stuff. The clothes are like, you know, there's like two pairs, two dark t-shirts so you can sweat and not see nothing.
But really, truly, are you really prepared to go at like any moment? Like, do you really have a bag type of thing ready? I do, yeah. He's just got to go back. It's crazy, yeah. Sean's got to go back. It's got two pounds of Skittles
and 50 little small things of soy sauce. Hey, Anderson, do you have a Dopp kit in there? By the way, we're going to ask you to follow up if you know where Dopp kit came from. But do you have a Dopp kit in there? A Dopp kit? What is it, Dopp? Dopp kit, Dopp kit.
Yeah, that's not what people call it, Will. That's why. They do call it a Dopp. It's a toiletry bag. It's not toiletry bag. It's called a Dopp kit. I'm not, I feel like a toiletry bag is a step of adulthood like Galash's or an umbrella,
which I'm not ready to commit to. Well, what do you call it? I'm not that organized. You don't have like what you call a toiletry bag? I don't have a bag, but I just put stuff in, like it's all free-floating in my bag. In a CVS bag? Hang on, hang on a sec.
You got your tooth, wait a minute. It's messy. Your toothbrush is banging around with the steel toes? Yeah. That's outrageous. This is a disaster. Okay, in all honesty, there's a pocket in the like the Doppel bag
that I put like all that stuff in, but it's all just floating around in that pocket. Yeah. We'll be right back. And now back to the show. So none of that scares the shit out of you. Like what is the draw? What is the thing inside of you that's like,
I gotta get to the middle of where everybody's shooting guns and bowling at bombs. It comes from a really healthy place. I'll tell you that. I mean, honestly, the honest answer, I mean, I don't want to bring it down, but yeah, my dad died when I was a kid. My brother died by suicide when I was 21, he was 23.
And I wanted to go places where the language of loss was spoken, where when you are feeling grief and dealing with loss and don't really know how to deal with it and you want to be around other people who are facing it and living through it and where it's not, where it's something people talk about and are living and it's very real.
Here, people don't talk about that stuff and it makes it worse if you're suffering. Did you know that before you went, or is this something that in retrospect you kind of understand? No, I was pretty aware. I mean, I didn't connect all the dots. Initially, I just had this impulse of like,
I drawn to, and mostly places where people are suffering that wasn't getting a lot of attention, that was sort of, the first place I went was Burma. I snuck into Burma and hooked up with some students fighting the Burmese government in the jungles and I shot a story of them. And then I ended up in Somalia in the early days of famine before the US got there
and the whole Black Hawk Down thing happened. It was in August of 92. And I was just drawn to places where, yeah, where people were suffering and where I, I mean, I wanted to tell their story. I wanted other people to know about it, but I also wanted to learn how to survive. Did it heal you?
I don't know about healing, but it, I learned I could survive and I learned how to survive from a lot of people I met. And I learned a lot about myself and a lot about other people and the power of people to get through the worst things that I've ever happened to them. Things which I don't think I could personally survive.
You know, people who have had horrific things done to them and every day get up and take care of their children and hold their head up high and in the face of it. It's like, and to that point, you touched on this a little bit. Like what is that culture shock from going to these other countries and then coming back to the United States
where people are like, you know, the most mundane issues. Like, I mean, we have real issues here, but what I'm saying compared to other countries. Yeah, I actually lived in L.A. When I first started, I was working for this thing called Channel One. It was seen in schools throughout America in the early 90s.
And it was in about half the schools. In America, it was a 12 minute daily newscast and I was like their foreign correspondent person. And I would come back to L.A., which is where it was based at Raleigh Studios, weirdly enough. And I just remember I was briefly in Rwanda during the genocide and I'd gone from the elections in South Africa for Mandela,
which was incredible to this horrific genocide in Rwanda. And I came back to L.A. And I just felt like I couldn't speak the same language as people and all I wanted to do was kind of just get on a plane and go somewhere else again. Yeah. Well, because it's real.
I mean, there's, it must feel very real or in some, to some degree, more real than what's going on. I mean, you're there dealing with this stuff and Sean's making a Bud Light commercial, you know? Back in the 90s. I mean, honestly, sorry, Sean, and you should be ashamed of yourself by this shameful. And I'm sure you are riddled with shame.
But no, but in truth though, I mean, that's a very, for a young man who's trying to process a lot of stuff, that's very, very heavy. And in a lot of way, you know what you're doing. You're subjecting yourself to it and you also know that you're doing it at the same time. Like there must have been a couple, you're kind of of two minds while it's happening.
Yes, no? No, that's 100%. And yeah, it makes regular life seem very dull and it's hard to return back to a regular life with that. All you want to do is kind of go back out. But when you're out, you're miserable and lonely and sad and it's horrific stuff around you and people are, you know, you're meeting people
who are stuck in these situations and you're gonna leave and that brings with it, it's all, it's its own sort of weirdness. Were there any complications or concerns about going into those areas given the family that you were coming from? Did you get any resistance from that, from your family or lawyers or somebody like,
hey, Anderson, hold on a second. You get kidnapped in this area. Like there's, I mean, seriously. No, no, my mom was actually amazingly supportive of it. I mean, she was alone and she was just her and I at that point and she was really cool about it. I mean, I sort of lied to her a lot early on. I'd be like, oh yeah, no, it's not so bad.
It's not so bad, it's not so bad like you see on TV when they exaggerate. I was in Egypt during the revolution against Mubarak and got attacked and I'd call my mom that morning and I was like, no, I'm just gonna stay by the pool today and hang out and of course, like there was no pool and I would not be staying by it. Wait, Anderson, can we go to Egypt?
Is it safe? You too, sure. I mean, I don't know, it's a little late, but you can't be good with that. Yeah, Scotty wants to go really, we wanna really go really bad. I mean, you know, it's not great for the gays, I gotta tell you.
I know that's what I heard, that's really hard. I mean, there's, well, I don't wanna, I mean. So we'll just call each other roommate. Yeah, is that right? I mean, you, I don't know, you're a well-known, but I mean, that brings with it, it's the one thing, like, you know, like, yeah, I'm not sure, you're a very well-known gay person.
Can you go? You know, I got beat up there, so I haven't been back since I got beat up, but. That's a great line of questioning, Sean. Wait, Anderson. By the way, triple, triple the number. I just wanna visit the pyramids, that's all. Now, Anderson, the stuff you've seen over there,
being all brave as you are, witnessing all of this stuff, is it, do you have a certain muscle that you've developed to sort of shed all those horrible things that could really wreck some folks, as far as visuals and memories and PTSD, and you've really been in a lot of tough spots. I don't, I don't think you, like, I think the job is to sort of bear witness to stuff,
and I think if you, if you don't allow yourself to be moved by it and changed by it, and if you're like this cold observer with a distance, you're not doing justice to the people who are there, and I think you need to expose yourself to it all. And so, yeah. Yeah, especially if your job is to relay that story to other folks.
Yeah, totally. To Jason's point, though, like, don't you, I mean, all of that stuff that is now that you can't unsee, that you've seen all these horrible things in the world, how does that affect you and your family now going forward? Like, what is one of the greatest things you learned in your journalism, you know, abroad, that you now apply to your family,
and or what do you try to withhold from your family, your kids? I mean, I think it shows you to embrace the beautiful moments that are possible in one's life and the extraordinary, I mean, the fact that I, as a gay man, can have children in this country, and we can marry if we want to, and I'm married,
but you appreciate all the more what there is, and you appreciate the kind of the moments of beauty and joy and love that you do actually find. Yeah, I love that. So then as a follow-up, and you see all this, we talk about all this horrible stuff that you've seen in your journalistic career overseas, or whatever, traumatic things, et cetera,
and then you're able to appreciate the fact that you have these freedoms that you enjoy as an American here in America. Are you worried about now, conversely, about seeing horrible things in this country, and we've all sort of been able to bear witness to a lot of a pretty darkened shift that seems rather dark as a newer American
than the three of you, that I find to be quite troubling and dark, and you talk about the freedom as a gay man to have kids and to be married, if you choose. We are entering a very dark age, and as a newsman, you've been right on the front line of it. Yeah, look, I mean, I'm optimistic about this country, and I'm optimistic about the people in this country,
and I think we're going through a very strange time, and but I choose to believe in the best in people, and I think we go, we tack left, we tack right, but we've moved forward as a country, and I hope that continues. But I do think people are capable of anything. I think we're all capable of anything. I think we have no idea, you have no idea
what happens when the electricity goes out and there's no windows and you're building anymore, and the wind is whipping through it, and it's the winter, and you can't feed your kids, you can't get them milk, and people are capable of anything, and I've seen that, and that worries me. I don't mean left or right.
I just mean in general, in terms of people, there's a sort of a sentiment that feels like it's very, there are some, there is a kind of a vibe that's nerve-wracking. I'll just put it that way. Yeah, but I'm with Anderson, and I'm sure you guys are too, that there's an optimism that is sort of impossible
and not to feel when you just think of the totality of this country and all the things that we've been through before. This is not the first time we've gone through real growing pains and border-pushing, and I think we'll land just fine, I hope. And by the way, I've seen plenty of places that have fallen apart and societies that have collapsed.
I mean, that's what interested me initially in going to places like that, and it is horrible, and nobody, I mean, whatever rhetoric people are saying here, the reality of that, if they actually see it, they will not be pushing for any kind of civil war. I mean, it is, what happens is a horrible, horrible thing. Right, right, right.
What are these, you know, like going back to the thing where you'd like have to drop everything at, you'd have to leave at the drop of a hat and pack and go to all these places. Don't you have to get like clearance and all this stuff, and everybody in the world knows who you are and they know that you're gay. So what about these countries where you have to go
to report where they're like, oh God, the gay guy from that channel is coming, and he's got clearance, we gotta let him in. You know, is that, do you ever? Sometimes, I mean, clearance is like visas sometime in some places, but for the most part, you just get on a plane and go and figure it out once you get there.
And yeah, I mean, initially I was traveling all by myself to Jason's point earlier, and that was, you know, ridiculously risky and stupid in a lot of places I was going. You know, in some places we have security, but it's, you know, it's a concern. I mean, it's definitely changed the security situation when I'm on the ground in places. The CNN thankfully is very cognizant of that,
but for the most part, you know, you have to go, I mean, I want to go still and you have to go and that's just part of the job. Yeah, so with your incredible position at CNN and at 60 minutes, you have the opportunity, I'm sure, to decide what stories you're going to do, things that are interesting to you that you might stumble upon or told about,
how do you decide which show to do the story for? How does that work? I mean, for the most part, you know, 60 minutes is, I do like 10 stories a year. The average correspondent does 20, so I do like a half load. And the, yeah, it's just stuff that interests me. And some of it is producers suggesting it.
Other times, you know, other times it's, I did a profile of Tony Bennett, you know, who was having his final concerts with Lady Gaga. And his family let us spend the, you know, months before the concert, leading up to it with Tony in his apartment and going through what he's going through. And so, I mean, that was, you know,
the chance to do that is just incredible. I got to, I got to, I had a piece on recently about this artist, Laurie Anderson, who I've loved since I was a teenager. Yes. She came out with the song, Oh Superman. And she's just cool. She's 75 and a lot of people don't know who she is.
And so, it's so cool to be able to be like, you know, Laurie Anderson's really interesting. Let's do a story. And 60 minutes is like, yeah, okay, sure. And so it doesn't have to be someone who has a movie or out, it can just be somebody who's kind of interesting. And that's amazing. I love that.
What happens if you get yourself a guest either on 60 minutes or on 360? And they're just not really giving you the answers that you either want to hear or that you know are correct. I hate the burning fire of a thousand songs. But you're so, you're so, you're a good dude. A good dude that you can just, you can see it. And so being confrontational is something
that I'm sure you're not that comfortable with, but it is part of your job. How do you reconcile those two things? Well, I mean, if someone's just not a good guest, I'm not gonna be confrontational with them because they're not a good guest. Although I do know a producer once, a producer at 60 Minutes once, I was with him in Niger.
And it was like a malnutrition crisis. And we had flown all the way there and we're doing the story about this thing called Plumpy Nut which is saving the lives of thousands, hundreds of thousands of kids over the years. Anyway, we go and we interviewed this doctor and it's just not going well. And like we've come all this way
and like we thought she was the character, but it's just not going well. And I try everything I can do. I, you know, all the little interviewing techniques, none of it works. Finally, the producer goes, you know what, you're like a boring professor from a class no one wants to take.
And I was like, okay, I think we're done here. I think. That's what the woman said? No, no, that's where the producer said to the woman and he was trying to like jump start, he was trying to like put the pads on her and like jump start her heart. It killed it.
And like, yeah, we ended up, you know, we saved the story. But so yeah, but I, that's not something I would ever say to somebody. But yeah, confrontation is not something I have a tradition of, but I will say, I've gotten to the point where I'm very comfortable in fronting people if they are not telling the truth, because it really pisses me off
when someone's not telling the truth. Yeah, but that necessitates you being as aware of the facts as this politician might. And that then I, my next question is, where do you find the time to be as educated as you need to be to do your job as well as you do it? So ideally, if you're doing an interview like that, that you know is going to be confrontational,
I mean, I spend hours reading, I try to read like everything that person has said, if you know it's going to be confrontational, if you know that they have stated things which are not true and you know, you want to zero in on it, you zero on in just a few points, and I try to read everything they've said
over the last like six months or six weeks, at least, because generally people repeat themselves over and over. So you can see in multiple interviews what somebody has already said, and then you know, okay, they're going to make, they're going to tell this lie, and then you have all the facts backed up. So if you, you know, if you do your research,
you have the advantage of knowing what they're going to say sometimes, and if they fall into that trap, then you can just say, okay, well, actually, here's the facts here, according to this organization, this organization, and there's nothing more satisfying than that. Yeah, you got the real silk glove and you do that.
Yeah, then burning somebody on TV. Well, it's not even so much burning them on TV, it's more just like just stating facts to somebody who has, because most people are doing interviews, you know, they pop up on the screen, they don't have the facts with them, so they can't really challenge somebody. So if you have the time to actually do the research,
there's nothing more satisfying than that. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Will wants to know where you get your news from. He always asks a journalist, where he thinks that there's like some- This is abatement, he's trying to cover up his own, he's always like, you get, the journalists have some secret channel of news.
Where do the news reporters get their news, if not from- They're reporting on the stuff that's happening, Dougie. Okay, where did Maggie Haberman get her information from after some of the sources? She wouldn't have interviewed people. Maggie Haberman has contacts that she has developed over the years, or whenever, and she contacts them
and she breaks news and then other people, sometimes people report what Maggie Haberman has said or we report the times it said, or we have folks at CNN who have the sources and that's what you either talk to people directly or- What do you think that Maggie Haberman's up in her bedroom, like fucking copying USA Today with her feet up in the air? Maggie, dinner's ready to hang on,
I'm just writing out my fucking story for tomorrow that I'm copying from another, what are you doing? But Anderson, Anderson is, he doesn't have, like he's not down in the underground parking lot, like Hal Hallbrook and Maggie Haberman. I'm not in the hall as the Mar-a-Lago talking to- Right, yeah, so like, so he's got an incredible staff, question mark and-
So yeah, so I've got, you know, for CNN here, you know, I've got a team of like 30 people and, but we have all these correspondents to rely on and all these guests to rely on and Maggie Haberman is a contributor to CNN and so we can bring her on and talk about what she's broken. So you've got a show tonight you're about to do, so I'd imagine, so you've got,
we're gonna let you go here soon and so you're gonna get in probably a big room with those 30 staff members and they're gonna say, here's what happened today, here's what you should know and yes? Yeah, I mean, this happens in the morning, so it's, we're talking in the almost evening on the East Coast and so that happened early this morning
of like, okay, we're our correspondents, what do we think is gonna happen? But stuff changes all throughout the day and even while we're on the air, stuff changes and so what you have to do basically is you have to just read stuff all day long. So I like reading, I like learning stuff, so you just read stuff all day long
so that in the middle of the program when what you think is gonna be the 45 minutes, the last 45 minutes of your show, gets tossed out because something else has happened, you already know enough in your head that you can talk about that for 45 minutes even if there's no teleprompter and there's no guests, there's nothing, you just have done a lot of reading.
That's so scary. Right, so like when there's something happens, let's say Jason, there's something, the so-and-so was indicted or whatever, that story is released, they make a statement, the clerks do whoever, whatever and the guys who work and women, everybody who works with Anderson, give them all that stuff and then they develop a story
based on those facts, you fucking idiot. No, but it is kind of interesting like the trickle down like all the people on the ground getting the story and then reports to this person and then reprises it and then it finally gets to you and then you put it on the air. Right, but the most interesting thing for a live television is you're on the air
and something happens, God forbid a plane crashes and all you have are a few sentences of information, you know the flight number, you know what time it took off, you know where it was supposed to go and so you go into rolling coverage and that means that everyone who's in the control room, it's suddenly like all hands on deck, they start calling flight experts, aviation experts,
anybody they can possibly think of, somebody from the Secretary of Transportation, the Department of Transportation, the MTSB, whatever it is. And on air, you start relaying the information, you point out what you don't know and you have an ongoing conversation that can go from anywhere from 30 seconds, you can be on for nine hours.
What are you doing when you get rid of all this out of your head and just to like check out, what are you doing with the kids, you're playing with the kids, what are you watching? I'm the most tightly wound person there is. What do you do to unwind? You start watching some of the Andy Cohen stuff and you just take you in a bunch of gummies,
what happens? So no, so this is gonna sound totally like I'm sucking up to you. I find it, I watch, I go home and I watch stuff that completely takes me out of my head and out of my world. So like Ozark, for instance, I am obsessed, I have loved it, I think it's one of the greatest shows,
no, one of the greatest shows in television. And it so takes me out of my head and into this other world, I find it relaxing. I found Ozark relaxing, I found Narcos relaxing. Oh yeah. Like Gamora, which is, I don't know if you've seen Gamora. Of course. It is the greatest, it's amazing.
But Ozark, it was so genius and the last season was genius and the end was incredible, the whole thing. You're very nice, thank you, I love it too. Yeah, and your character, I'm the same way of like, oh, okay, that person just got shot in the head. Okay, so now we have to do this. All right, so let's do that. So that is how I deal with everything.
Yeah, same, I'm a little bit of a... Let me ask you about Gamora. Did you see the Chiro spin-off movie? I did, I didn't love it. Yeah, I didn't love it either. But you know what, I don't want to criticize anything about Gamora, because I just, I didn't even like the movie, Gamora so much.
The TV show, I just, it's mind-blowing. Did you, and I'm not here to one-up you, Anderson, I think you're great. Oh boy. Did you read the book? I did, actually. Yeah, it's great. The book is great.
Yeah. Roberto Saviano, it's fucking great. Yeah, who's been in hiding ever since he wrote this stuff. I read his, he had another book, his most recent book I read, which I didn't really get into, but... Did you get that one, Redwell? I did not.
I did not read the book. Oh, you didn't? Oh, huh, I'll send it to you. Interesting, and we're back, and we're back. So what, now the New Year's, the New Year's thing seems like I get the hair down, relax a little bit, think, how did that come about? Did you raise your hand for that?
Yeah, and how many releases do you have to sign into CNN just like, man, just fucking cool it this year? You know, it's funny, so I've been doing that for like, I just, I started volunteering to do New Year's because I hated New Year's Eve. I started volunteering like 15 years ago, because no one at CNN was doing it, and they needed somebody,
and I was like, I hate New Year's Eve, you can't have fun, there's too much pressure. Clubs in New York, like there's too many long lines. Right. You end up fighting over cabs with drunk girls. So I was like, you know what, I'll just work on New Year's Eve, and I'd never been in Times Square's on New Year's Eve,
and it turned out I actually really liked it, it was fun, I could come and go, and so yeah, and then Andy joined, and it's been fun. Yeah, it's like the one thing I look forward to that evening. You guys are great at it. And he's, you know, he enjoys a little drink now and then, and so he broke me into that. God, he's fun, he's a fun dude.
Now, when you mentioned your mom finding out about, you know, you doing all this and wanting to go out in crazy situations in other countries, and be, you know, like that, are you do, what would you do if one of your sons came up and said, you know what, Dad, I'm gonna run out to the store really quick, and they're in Bosnia or whatever. Um, you know, well, you know, my son's two,
so if he did that, I would be really concerned. When they're older, when they're older. Okay. Bosnia is actually gorgeous right now. Yeah, okay, sorry. Oh, it's this time of year, it's nice. Yeah. You know, look, I hope I would be the parent
who's supportive of anything my kids want to do, and I would have a like a team of special force, former special forces, people secretly following him around. I'm sure, I'm sure. Now, before we let you go, I want to hear about your podcast. Now, so it's called All There with Anderson Cooper. Now, this is.
It's called All There Is, but that's fine. No, that's all there is. All There Is. All There, well, good change, good change there. So started with all that, no. Is it, this has to do with a bit of your life before journalism, yes? Yeah, especially, it's a podcast,
like The World Needs Another podcast, but it's just a limited podcast, eight or 10 episodes or something, and it's about loss and about grief, and it's about, yeah, it's about people's experiences with that and living with that and moving through it, and it's something we don't really talk about, I think, and makes people uncomfortable,
so I don't know if anyone will actually listen to it, but it's just interesting people who have kind of remarkable experiences, talk with loss and grief in their own life, from Stephen Colbert, who I know you guys have had on, I loved your episode with him, his father and his twin brothers were killed in a plane crash when he was 10 years old,
Molly Shannon, who has had the incredible experiences as well, and just really interesting people, a palliative care doctor who's been at the bedside of many people as their life ended, and so it's just about, it's not depressing, it's just kind of talking about loss and grief. It's part of life, and we had Michael Lewis, the author, on a while ago,
and he talked about loss in a way that I'd never heard anybody talk about, and it's really remarkable and very moving, and I think you're right, I think it is important to talk about it, and I'll listen to it, I'm looking forward to it. Yeah, you could walk us through any subject, and it would be palatable for sure.
Listen, nobody has more losses than me, okay? I mean, let's get real, all right? You poor guy. You have a lot of losses. Now, for fun with the kids, what do you love to do? What are they loving? So my son Wyatt is like two years in like three or four months,
and my son Sebastian is six months old, and they are just, I mean, I always wanted to be a dad, I love kids, and it's the greatest thing I've ever done, it's the only thing, I mean, I just am so besotted with them, and I like nothing more than, you know, I spend most, a lot of the day with them,
I mean, I do a lot of work now just from home, I love being there when he wakes up in the morning, I like going in and waking him up in the morning, and going out, we go out for coffee, and like, his first phrase was, I want a black, a coffee, which is probably not a great thing for a two-year-old. I want a black coffee.
So you've got, now that you've got two kids, and you're able to compare the two of them, and also the sort of the age difference there, most fibbers will say that they love the first year, now I'm sure you're gonna say the same thing, but now that you've got one that's beyond the first year, two and a half, don't like, isn't it amazing? Not quite two.
No, two and a half in six months, right? Almost two and a half, almost two and a half. So to me, it was like my dog learned how to talk, you know, because the whole first year, that's all they are is that they're just a puppy, they're shitting everywhere and screaming, and you just, there's no communication, and then all of a sudden, they learn how to say,
I like this park and not that park, or this food and not that food, and it's like, right through the ceiling. I know, and this morning, like, my son, he came, like, I came upstairs right before I left for work, and he saw me, he ran to me, and like, hugged me, and which, you know, obviously he's done before,
but he's just so pret, he's so there now, like, he's, I know, you know, he's all baked in there, like, I just need to not fuck him up, I just need to not, like, pass on my insane controlling, you know. You won't. I got you. I got you.
But I totally agree with you, I've been like, the dog who's now talking, it's the best thing ever, it's like, oh my God, I couldn't, I didn't think it could get any better, I feel like my head and my heart are about to explode. So what did you do, Anderson, what did you do, because you just said it, and I know this about you, everything has to be in order,
maybe a little bit just controlling, maybe just, like, everything has its place, and then now you have two little adorable, amazing boys who throw things, knock things over, dirty shit up, right on the wall, like, whatever it is, does that, what does that do to you? You know, I like to keep their stuff, ultimately a little clean when they go to bed,
I clean out a little bit, but I don't, but I don't, like, I don't wanna pass on any of that stuff, so I'm like, you know what, they have an entire floor to themselves, I'm on the floor right beneath, I live in an old firehouse, and you know, it's their floor, and I'm fine with it.
Wait, you live in an old firehouse, I thought that you lived in the Time Warner Center, that you just had a fire pole, that's how I imagine how you live, that you just went down. But is there a fire pole, that's always my dream, by the way, true story. Yeah, I kept the fire poles, of course.
Truly? Yeah. Oh my God, I wanna come over. There's a stable in the back for horses, because the engines were horsed over. Please let me come over, I wanna slide down that thing. Amazing. So what I'm getting is,
your kid's living on a different floor than you. He said it. Yeah, yes. People have different bedrooms, you and Scotty have different bedrooms. That's true, that's true. We sleep in separate bedrooms. Anderson, you go do your thing,
and we love you, making that stuff we love to watch. I really love what you guys do, and I can't believe I've been able to be on this, and it's... It's okay, you can say you love us too. Yeah, I can say it. Well, thank you for doing this. You're real, real busy.
You could have easily said no, but thank you for not. Thank you. Thank you. Thanks, Anderson. It's great to meet you. It's such a pleasure. All right, thank you guys. Bye, pal.
See you guys, bye. I really like that fellow, guys. I don't care who knows it, I'll scream it from the rooftops. He's entertaining all the way around. I'm real sweet on him. I like it when he starts to break, when he starts to laugh, he's really funny.
Yeah, he starts to titter. If you don't expect this, he starts to titter. Yeah, it's really fun. But brilliant, like journalists, but also, I was gonna ask him because Jason in your intro, you said how private this person was. I was like, oh, I wonder how they're gonna be as a guest. And you revealed that it was Anderson.
And I know how private he was before he came out. He, there seemed to be something, I was gonna say this to him and I'll say this to him to his face, but a little not fully there. And then after he came out, it was like, oh, there's the guy. Now he's hosting New Year's Eve, now he's out
and he's proud and he's happy as his family, he's a lot to share. And you see it now when he reports on TV and stuff. I think it's really, really great. I wonder if he felt like the sort of that. I don't know if it was the gay thing or not, I'm sorry. Well, but maybe like, because he wanted to be a respected journalism guy
and Edward R. Murrow and Walter Cronk. This guy, this guy, don't know what he's talking about. And he needs to be all buttoned up. And then once he, yeah. So now he's like, yeah. So maybe that was a part of it. Maybe that, yeah. I feel like he needed to.
But anyway, super, super guy, so, and by the way, funny, like really funny. Yeah, I'd like, listen, as I said, I'd like to spend more time with him. I don't know if you guys have a number on him. I do, I have all its contact info. He doesn't have a number. Over gay, all the gay people have each other.
Is that right? I feel like you're joking, but is that true? Oh, he's assumed that. It's the yellow pages, the gay yellow pages. Wonderful stuff. I had so many, I had a bunch of really good jokes. I would tell you this, this is the respect that I ever understood.
I'm surprised you didn't have anything for plumpy nut. I thought, I did, I did. I know that really stuck out to me too. Guys, I love you. We're not doing anything clever today, but saying, Hi. Oh, we are?
Just that? Yeah, because- Well, you can hang up. Will and I are gonna think about something that's worthy of our listener. Yeah, we had a great listener. I was not saying it was against the listeners. Yeah, the listener, you know,
what if somebody just tunes in for that? Right. You know, they're just like- If we could reach one kid. They put out, there's a three-time speed until they get, yeah, until they get to the end. So we're gonna sit here. Sean, but you know what?
Sean, I tell you what though, I'm not gonna be mad at you, you know why? Because I'm gonna let bygones be bygones. Wonderful. Wonderful. Smart. Smart. Loss.
SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Bennett Barbaco, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Amjarf. Smart. Loss. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.